today I'm going to talk about AI and
thus a researchers have always said that
we humans do not need to worry because
only menial jobs will be taken over by
machine is that really true they have
also said that hey I will create new
jobs so those who lose their jobs we'll
find a new ones of course but the real
question is how many of those who may
lose their jobs to AI will be able to
land a new one
especially when AI is smart enough to
learn better than most of us let me ask
you a question how many of you think
that AI will pass the entrance
examination of a top university by to
suddenly training oh really yeah okay so
um some of you may say that of course
yes now seniority is issues and some
others may say maybe because they're
already won against the top girl player
and others may say no never mmm that
means we do not know the answer yet
right said that was the reason why I
started Todai Robert Project making an
AI which passes the entrance examination
of the University of Tokyo the top
university in Japan so this is our total
robot and of course the brain of the
robot is working in the remote server
it is now writing 600 words si maritime
trade in the 17th century how does it
turn ok why did I take the entrance exam
as its benchmark because I thought
we had to study the performance of AI in
comparison to humans especially are the
skills and expertise which are believed
to be acquired only by humans and only
through education to enter Todai the
University of Tokyo you have to pass two
different types of exams the first one
is a national standardized test in
multiple-choice file you have to take
seven subjects and achieve high score I
would say like 85% or more accuracy rate
to be allowed to take the second stage
written test prepared by Todai so let me
first explain how modern AI works taking
Jo body challenge as an example here is
a typical job OD question motels lost
Symphony shares its name with this
planet interestingly Jubilee question
always asks always ends with this
something this planet this country this
rock musician and so on in other words
jeopardy doesn't ask many different
types of question but the single type
which we call factoid questions by the
way do you know the answer if you do not
know the answer and if you want to know
the answer what would you do you Google
right of course why not but you have to
pick appropriate keywords like Mozart
last and symphony to search machine
basically does the same then this
Wikipedia page will be ranked top then
machine reads the page
nah-uh unfortunately none of the modern
way eyes including Watson Siri and Todai
Robert is able to read
but they are very good at searching and
optimizing it will recognize that the
keywords Motel loss and Symphony are
appearing heavily around here so if it
can find the word which is a planet and
which is co-occurring with these
keywords that must be the answer this is
how but soon finds the answer Jupiter in
this case our Todai Robert works
similarly but a bit smarter in answering
to history yes/no questions like cell
may repelled the measures is the
sentence true or false our robot starts
producing a factoid question like Sal
may repel this person type by itself
then Ava's buttnik Marge's is ranked top
their sentence is likely to be false our
robot does not read does not understand
but it is statistically correct in many
cases for the second stage written test
it is required to write 600 was si like
this one and as I have shown earlier our
robot took the santoses from the
textbooks and a Wikipedia combined them
together and optimize it to produce an
essay without understanding a thing but
it's surprisingly it wrote the better si
the most of the students how about
mathematics fully automatic math solving
machine has been a dream since the birth
of the word artificial intelligence but
it has stayed at the level of arithmetic
for
long time last year we finally succeeded
in developing a system for its salt free
university level problems from end to
end like this one this is original
problem written in Japanese and we have
to teach it mm mathematical actions and
8,000 Japanese words to make it except
the problems written in natural language
and it is now translating the original
problems into machine readable farmers
weird but it is now ready to solve it I
think go and solve it yes it is now
executing symbolic computation even more
weird but probably this is the most fun
part for the machine right now it output
a perfect answer there it's proof is
impossible to read even for
mathematicians anyway last year
Robert was a man top 1 cent 1% in the
second stage written exam in mathematics
thank you sir did it enter Todai no not
as I expected
why because it doesn't understand any
meaning let me show you a typical error
it made in English test
two people are talking
for us who can understand the situation
it is obvious number 4 is the correct
answer
right but toda Robert chose number 2
even after
learning 15 billion English sentences
using deep learning technologies okay so
now you might understand what I said
modern ears do not read do not
understand they only disguise as yes
they do this is the distribution graph
of a half a million students who took
the same exam as today Robert now Alec
toda Robert is a man top 20% and it was
capable to pass more than 60% of the
universities in Japan but not Todai
but see how it is beyond the volume zone
of two big white collar workers you
might think I was delighted
after all my Robert was suppressing
students everywhere instead I was
alarmed her an earth could dis an
intelligent machine are the performed
students our children right I decided to
investigate what was going on in the
human world
I took hundreds of San assess from the
tech high school textbooks and made easy
multiple-choice quizzes and asked
thousands of high school students to
answer here is an example of course the
original problems are written in
Japanese their mother tongue okay
obviously Christianity is down sir isn't
it it's written and told I Robert chose
the correct answer to but one-third of
the
high-school students fail to answer to
this question do you think it is only
the case in Japan I do not think so
because Japan is always ranked among the
top in OECD Pisa test measuring 15 year
old students performance in mathematics
science and reading every three years we
have been believing that everybody can
learn and learn well as long as we
provide good learning materials free on
the web so that they can accept through
the internet but such wonderful
materials may benefit only theirs who
can read well and the percentage of
those who can read well may be much less
than we expected how we humans will
coexist with AI is something we have to
think about carefully based on solid
evidences at the same time we have to
think in the hurry because time is
running out thank you thank you thank
you in your talk you so beautifully give
us a sense of what of how a eyes think
what they can do amazingly what they
what they can't do but do I read you
right that you think that we really need
quite an urgent revolution in education
to help kids do the things that humans
can do better guys yes yes because you
know we humans can understand the
meaning that is something which is very
very lacking in AI but most of the
students just Park the knowledge without
understanding the meaning of the
knowledge so that is not knowledge that
is just memorizing and AI can do the
same thing so we have to think
but new type of education a shift from
knowledge wrote knowledge to meaning
well there's a challenge for the
educators here thank you
[Applause]